con un chaleco antibalas y portando un
rifle el asediado presidente de belarús
alexander lukashenko no pareció
inmutarse por quienes exigen su renuncia
lo que le generó una ronda de aplausos
por parte de los uniformados
pero otra escena muy diferente se daba
en las calles de minsk donde se
reunieron unos 100.000 manifestantes
opositores al gobierno la protesta más
grande hasta ahora desde que lukashenko
ganó un sexto mandato vine aquí contra
la injusticia quiero un cambio quiero
libertad quiero vivir en un país libre
varias fábricas cruciales para la ya
debilitada economía del país también han
sido golpeadas por la huelga de los
trabajadores que se unen a las protestas
pero si estos manifestantes no son
amigos de lukashenko rusia ciertamente
lo es el ministro de relaciones
exteriores dijo que el camino a seguir
debe estar en los términos del
presidente muy disco de nuestro gusto no
es necesario imponer ninguna receta a
belarús el presidente lukashenko ha
dicho repetidamente durante sus
recientes reuniones con los trabajadores
que apoyaba el diálogo incluida la
propuesta más importante un diálogo
sobre la reforma constitucional este es
un camino muy prometedor nuevismo la
reelección de lukashenko que él dice que
ganó de manera aplastante ha sido
ampliamente desacreditada el líder de 65
años ha afirmado que los manifestantes
son agitadores influenciados por fuerzas
extranjeras y que
en parte de una conspiración liderada
por occidente para desestabilizar al
país